one of the things that i really love
with coming to this venue and especially
this stage
there are two things one is the size of
these speakers are amazing so i can i
can play music much better than i can do
back at home another part is that this
stage is technically floating means that
every time i go up on it i need to
consider my own mortality i am not
entirely sure that i will survive the
event but i'll take it
this is the untruthful art
this has also been called the angry
swede for an hour
i'll come back to why
this session for starters it's not
designed to make people uncomfortable
it's not designed to make people
angry
it has been known to do just that and
again that is not my intention but as we
walk through these five scenarios and
five things
you're gonna see exactly why my blood
pressure tends to rise as i do this
session
in the name the untruthful art it's a
nod to one of the the seminal works
within data visualization it's called
the truthful art it was written by
alberto cairo he's one of the the
absolute giants when it comes to
database he reached out on twitter
about a year back and said oh that's a
nice
nice name of your session
i needed a pair of new underpants
but he was very kind he wasn't angry at
all he just thought it was kind of a
cool thing
let's kick off
we live in the world of information
in 2021
it's been estimated to be about 74
trillion
gigabytes of data that's 74 zettabytes
i suspect that more than half of that is
probably porn and spam
and the rest is evenly divided between
cat pictures
um
music and selfies and maybe
at the corner some useful data
but how much of it is true
well i wish there was a
way of explaining what true is but we
can't it's just too complex
and in this world of complexity
there are ways to leverage this
not only the information itself but also
the information overload to push an
agenda to change outcomes
and the only thing that's worth worse
than being played
that's being played without you knowing
it
we're going to spend the next hour
talking about these things we're going
to look at what deception look like
some of it is going to be plain obvious
some of it isn't
some of it that's going to make you
pissed
how to spot foul play
most of the time unless someone is lying
to your face
there are going to be some red flags not
always
but often
and
we're also going to see what makes the
data visualization craft so extremely
dangerous
most of us are predominantly visual
that means that we take in visual
information and do a lot with it
thus we're kind of susceptible to
everything that i'm going to show you
my name is alexander
uh
i'm going to tell you that in a bit
my goal today i should say um
is to show you the central tenet of
visual trickery
ourselves
we see
what we want to see
literally
so
by creating a possible narrative
i can mislead just about anyone
and that's all it takes
my name is alexander i am not an
american
i am a swede i.e from slightly to the
right of norway i have spent 24 years in
data anything from databases to
analytics the whole nine yards if
there's data i'm doing it it's kind of
neat to be able to say yes i work with
data or in sweden
then again it turns out for the ones in
here that actually speak swedish that
picture walking into a bar and going
you're going to go home alone
ask me how i know
so yeah
i work as a principal solutions
architect for atollo in sweden a
stockholm based bi company that is
probably the best title i've ever had
because nobody knows what i do
the thing is it's kind of easy to
explain what i do because i make data
matter
only data that matters can have any
impact on anything and that's at the end
of the day it's all about business it's
not about tech
i um i used to
go all over the world
to speak at conferences to teach courses
and all that stuff and then the world
ended and i've kind of been stuck in my
home office it's a great home office but
i'm pretty sure that the walls are
actually moving slowly engineer
so it's so good to be able to go out
until the world ended again yesterday
but this still it's much better than my
home office just just saying
if you were in my home office
i'd be kind of concerned
i'm one of seven data platform mvps in
sweden i co-host a podcast called native
in tech i have some stickers everybody
loves those i have it on good authority
that a computer with stickers is a
faster and happier computer but you
didn't know that
so just grab any stickers you want and
for
the people in here that are my age or
older yes that is the doom game logo
probably the best game ever done
so let's
go to
the first part this is greta
great is angry
she's very
very angry
because she's gotten into her little
head that the world is going to
and she's kind of concerned about this
and would very much prefer that the
world leaders would do something about
it
is the world going to
well
maybe maybe not
let's look at a few things this was put
on
by the national review a um an american
outfit that's um
what do you call it a conservative news
outlet and this is in fahrenheit so i
apologize for that but they basically
say that this is the only climate change
chart you'll ever need to see
might drop
really
do we have any issues with this oh boy
yes we do
so
let's look at what this actually means
for starters
we can't work with
that scale
for starters let's look at the data
around 57 degrees fahrenheit or 13.7
degrees centigrade
this is where the
the interesting things happen
we can start to see a bit of a trend and
it's slowly inching upwards right
what's even more interesting is that
this is the absolute numbers
it's not the change
and then there's the small detail that
this is the average ocean temperature
for the entire globe do you think that
there might be some local changes and
local differences between the different
corners of the globe
oh
maybe let's look at the actual change
i.e the anomaly
it would seem that yes
we are changing and yes there is a
pretty decent reason for greta to be
pissed
this is it
this is what the data actually shows us
all right it's going to get worse
let's shift into something else
so everything around numbers in in a
visual in a chart like this is called
scaffolding
we have the axes we have the labels all
that stuff
what if we were a company selling the
absolute latest in
cat fashion
we can see that the conversion rate
which is the number of people going to
our website and
going from just browsing to actually
buying anything
it's skyrocketed in april since my bonus
is based off the conversion rate i'm
going to be rich i'm going to be filter
rich just look at april holy yeah
yeah no
small detail
big blue arrow pointing to the y axis
if i force the y axis
to six percent i am forcing everything
to be relative to that number meaning
that holy cow it's an enormous change in
april what it might actually be looking
like this
this is what we should do we should have
a zero as a baseline
suddenly yes
it's a better conversion rate in april
that's fine but it's not this enormous
change it's not
an
artifact artificially large change
so um how do we do this well in power bi
which is my stomping ground i
do just about only microsoft stuff
you set the
uh the the chart to to auto basically
that that's how it will sort the
zero on itself it's not if it's not set
on auto well you can go in and set it as
zero or auto
okay
if you want really good examples of how
to completely screw people over when it
comes to visuals i highly recommend fox
news
in fact
i considered calling this session an
hour with fox news
i don't think i would ever be allowed
back in the u.s
and case in point i haven't done this
session in the u.s i don't think i will
there's a reason for that
fox news does amazing things to data or
i should say horrible things it's kind
of the same thing in this case
just look at this wonderful graph
somebody
stole
the y-axis
yeah
we're going to come back to that
so the y-axis is gone
again there's a reason for that
something's kind of funky with the
x-axis as well
what is funky well the
the points are not equidistant
they have just arbitrarily put these num
points out
meaning that they have an almost perfect
line
that's a bit of a warning sign roughly
the size of texas
um okay so what do we do well you've
kind of started to see the pattern let's
look at the actual base data that data
can be found at the bureau of labor
statistics
and it looks like this
okay let's plot out the everything that
we see
so we are starting with the
arbitrarily pointed
numbers right so the distance between
december of 7 september 8th well it's
not the same as september 8th to march
09 and so on and so forth so let's move
these things a tad so it actually looks
like the way it should look
um
yeah no my straight line kind of went to
it kind of went out the window didn't it
but it's worse
because there is a crap ton of data that
they didn't bother to put in there
because if you actually overlay the data
on all the data points it looks like
this
and bye-bye went my straight line
funny that
and finally for the first part
i'm going to give you this
it's kind of a serious uptick at the end
right
yeah
the reason for this
because someone had a bit of a meltdown
and created a logarithmic scale all of a
sudden
seriously why would you do that
we had a great thing going with 80 90
1999 99 no
no you don't do this ever and if you do
you should put it out in huge texts
i did something here
okay what can we conclude from this well
first of all look at the scaffolding
look at everything that is around the
actual graph
and if it's not there ah danger will
there almost endanger there is a reason
why the scaffolding is not there i'm
going to show you something called fluff
in a bit kind of the same thing
also
if you have a bar chart or generally if
you have any charts at all the axis
should go to zero because that is going
to be your baseline something to compare
everything to
there might be specific reasons why you
don't want to go for a zero and that's
fine but again if you don't make sure
you point it out
and for the love of everything that is
holy do not
change
axis
scales midstream
because i will find you
right so let's go for cherry picking
and cherry picking is kind of the art of
choosing the data that fits your
narrative
and if it's done in science it's going
to be called p hacking p for
statistical probability
um the rest of the world is just called
shenanigans but people really
consider it now
it's kind of an inception thing that i'm
going to do here let's see if you catch
it
let's start with this
what am i just doing well i'm doing a
couple of things
first of all i am expecting
each and every one of you to have seen
star wars
if you don't we have a bit of an issue
i might be a bit of a star wars fan just
saying now so most people have seen star
wars most people know the premise of the
evil empire and the
overlord darth vader and that the
stormtroopers have a pretty limited life
expectancy if they don't follow his
rules well some actually do follow the
rules and still perish that's a whole
different story
so
by choosing who i ask
and frame the question
in the way that i can control the
answers well suddenly
why
why am i doing this i am creating a
question and i'm forcing you down a very
narrow path because there is just one
correct answer
that's cherry picking in a nutshell
so how do we how do we do this
in in data well first started let's
let's go to sweden did you know
did you know
that sweden turns out to be the second
most dangerous country in europe
huh
interesting i didn't know that and i was
born there
uh this is according to a site called
namvio.com
so by filtering on on crime index by
country in 2020
sweden sticks out like a sore thumb we
are in great company with the ukraine
and france and ireland and moldova
are some issues with this
first one is this is self-reported
meaning not only do you need to
find this site
you also need to go in and put in data
i kind of see that this is going to
happen on friday evening
after a beer or two
and nobody bothered to
define
danger
so it's gonna be
yes sweden is very very dangerous
so what do we do well
before we look at the data who do you
think uses this
well
this has been quoted by the
more shall we say racist parts of the
swedish political establishment
let's look at the data
again let's look at the data this is
available
underneath
apparently
the number of reported crimes are going
up yep that's a fact
the number of
um
manslaughters and murder ones and all
that stuff is staying at a fairly stable
level
now this does not take into account the
latest
shootings we've had an uptick in in
shooting especially in my city
uh kind of a bummer but it's not part of
this this um uh this chart
so what we can conclude here is that the
number of crimes being reported is going
up
that's the only thing that we can
conclude this does not mean that we're
living in a more dangerous
time
huh
another great example of cherry picking
this was run by a site called
economicshelp.org and it was designed to
to show cherry-picking
the uk is still on everybody's lips
after the
disastrous brexit
yeah i'm not going to be able to do this
session in the uk either for reasons
that you're going to find in a bit
and
this does look a bit strange
because again if we were to look at our
old friend the x-axis we're going to see
that they have kind of constrained this
between 1995 and 2016.
i'm pretty sure that
they had some inflation stuff going on
before 1995
probably after 2016 as well so what if
we go and dig out the base data again
suddenly looks like this
they managed to find the smallest part
in the data that supports their
narrative
what can we conclude from this data does
not have its own voice
data is not going to tell you
that you don't decide it says
or the people trying to
tell you
so don't trust
data
ever
and uh case in point this was put on on
put up on twitter
i think it was three or four months ago
i'm i'm just stumbled upon it and i i
decided then that yeah this is going to
go into my session so bernborg is a
danish i think
science denier or client's client
climate skeptic or climate
change denier he put up this one and
said well apparently this is not as big
an issue that people think it is
unfortunately for him
andrew destler who is a professor of
atmospheric sciences and a climate
scientist at texas a m
found this and went
ah wait a second that's kind of weird
because yes the 30s they were hot
but they were not that hot
and why on earth isn't the 2010s showing
up at all
something is strange now
this is epa data
so the environmental protection agency
has put this out this is correct
validated verified data
why does it look the way it does
a couple of reasons
so for starters
this is plotting what's known as the
heat wave index
and if i were to ask any of you what the
heat wave index would be we'd have a lot
of great answers none of them would be
correct
i'm reading verbatim
a heat wave index counts the occurrence
of four day heat waves of temperatures
exceeding one in a 10-year recurrence
okay that's a kind of a
different
view on things
so
by choosing this
extremely
strange metric
you can show this
what if we change the the way we look at
heatwave to something more reasonable
instead perhaps
let's look at the the actual
temperatures
and compare that suddenly we're going to
look at this
huh
so the 30s yes they were warm
they were not that warm
and then we've had a gradual increase
back to the 2010s and 2020s
the funny thing is that there's actually
two cherry picks in this single thing
the first one was choosing the very
obscure metric
the second one
this is just the u.s
the world looks a bit different funny
that
so no mr lomborg
you can crawl back under your stone
what can we learn from this well look at
the agenda
someone is always trying to sell you
something if you don't know what they're
selling you might be the product i think
you've heard that before
and consider the responders if i were to
ask a
very homogenous group something and ask
another group that has nothing to do
with the first group the same question
we might have two completely different
answers
just saying
and finally
try to examine the base data if you can
we have so much data available to us
it might be kind of a
difficult proposition to to find your
way in and find the base data but most
of the time it is there
and you're going to find that a lot of
times what's reported is not necessarily
supported by the actual data
so let's look at comparisons
comparisons while comparing things
they're kind of a classical way of
driving a narrative
there's a saying that
one would compare apples to apples but
i'll show you some creative ways of
comparing both basically apples to
trombones and in case anybody's
wondering that's a six-valve military
trombone from 1866.
comparing stuff is hard it's even harder
if you lack basic literary skills
literacy skills uh how many weeks do we
have in august again
um yeah no not these many
at all
where do you think i found this picture
which tv station
yes fox news
anyways let's go back to the relative
dangers of living it turns out that
living is actually terminal you're not
going to get away with
your life but that's a different story
in it of itself
so
this is a visual that plots the relative
danger i.e the most dangerous cities in
the us
we have this small infographic that
shows you the relative danger i don't
know how you measure danger is that in
kilos or in meters i don't know and this
is what's known as fluff
there is data here but there's also a
crapton of cool visuals and graphics and
stuff
that does nothing
except make your eyes go
like this
you don't know what you're looking at
so if we were to clean this up remove
all the fluff and just look at the
actual data this is what we're going to
find
so chicago is
kind of um at the top here and the top
10 most dangerous cities in the u.s
are we missing something
yeah
where's my scale where's my x-axis
somebody misplaced my x-axis so let's
put that in
so this is actually number of homicides
per city from 2019.
do we have any issues with this yes we
do i was never very good at geography
but even i know that there's a bit of
its size difference between chicago
8.9 million people and baltimore the 2.3
million people so if you were to compare
the the absolute number of people
killed
you are probably going to see some
differences in the numbers
what do we do well
yes we're going to come back and look at
the data
but we are going to
control for the size of the city
we can do that by simply saying the
homicide rates per 100 000 residents per
city
where did um chicago go
huh
chicago is not that dangerous apparently
well baltimore is still more difficult
and st louis you don't want to go there
but again
the fluff
didn't show you this
and if you don't control precise
this is what you end up with
and then we have this this was sent to
me
by a
former colleague of mine that i've said
from the start of this pandemic i am not
going to touch kobe 19 data with a 10
foot stick because the data is horrible
you cannot compare kovid 19 data that's
all i'm going to say on that he sent me
this and said this is an interesting
example of what
well let's see what this actually shows
this is from the uk and this is the the
hospitalized patients and we can see
that scotland had a pretty crappy day
and what's going on in northern ireland
i don't know
look at the y-axis
yeah
so at the top of england we have 30 000
at the top of northern ireland
we have 700.
you cannot compare these what are people
going to do well we're predominantly
visual so we're going to look at the
shapes of the
the the visuals and it apparently seems
like the northern ireland part is a
bit iffy
you do not compare these like this you
need to have a common baseline
this is the bbc
if anyone should
these people should know better
then we can look at revenue and as we
can see from my company i am rich i'm
becoming richer just just look at my
revenue it's going up up and away
kind of awesome uh but if we were to um
oh i don't know
look at the
the y-axis again
kind of a large sum of money
500 millions a thousand millions
also known as a billion
one and a half billion
something is kind of funky here it's
just it keeps going
why is this well it's because we're
looking at cumulative revenue
and if you weren't told that this is
cumulative revenue no we kind of again
look at it and go yeah seems reasonable
this is what it actually looks like
but since it's cumulative you need to
have a pretty serious
deficit
in order for this the
the line to dip downwards
so be careful when you compare
cumulative or absolute revenues or
numbers at all
compare apples to apples do not put any
trombones in your data
taken out of context that is a very
strange sentence
compared to what
always have a baseline
i'm the best speaker ever
compared to my cats
my cats have never been on stage
so yes you need to compare to something
reasonable my cats are not reasonable
and please consider absolute versus
community
cumulative increases
it might look the same on a graph
but look at the scaffolding look at the
text look at the description what are we
what are we trying to show you
and
it's time to take a turn for the worse
correlating causation
so
what does this mean causation this is
the action of causing something i'm sure
you've heard correlation does not imply
causality more than once
and that is extremely true
but it is also something that very few
people
realize what it means
i'm going to show you for starters this
did you know that the per capita
consumption of cheese in the u.s and the
total revenue generated by golf courses
each year actually correlate
ha
but they do not
what
they're not not causal
i can guarantee you
that there is no causation
between the consumption of cheese
and the revenue generated by golf
courses
there is nothing driving the other
they happen to correlate
they don't drive each other
hold that in your minds
because i'm going to show you something
terrible
this is
glyphosate
or as it's more commonly known as
roundup
roundup is a weed killer brought to
market by the monsanto corporation in
and it's been called
many things
for instance in in 1996 the attorney
general of new york
ordered monsanto to pull ads that said
that well roundup is safer than table
salt
um it was also practically non-toxic to
mammals birds and fish
the debate whether
this is carcinogenic or not is still
raging today
and i mean it's hard to figure out
what's true or not because
there's been several lawsuits regarding
this and people have been paid
inordinate amounts of money for it for
claiming that this caused the cancer
i don't know but
in 2015 the world health organization's
international agency for research on
cancer iarc
they classified glyphosate
as probably carcinogenic in humans
in contrast the european food safety
authority
concluded in november of the same year
2015 that the substance is unlikely to
pose a carcinogenic threat to humans
i don't know
and that's the thing
nobody knows
but the lack of firm evidence does not
mean that people don't create these kind
of visuals
so um and while we're at it why don't we
just toss genetically modified crops
under the boss as well
there are a few weird things going on
here both stuff that we see and stuff
that we do not see
i mean
there's a few things that i i want you
to point out i want to point out to you
how for instance can we have
minus
of something
how can we have minus on a scale like
this well the reason for it to be minus
is to have the intercept i.e the way
that the lines
intercept and intersect each other to
kind of look good
this is classic manipulation of a visual
the whole point
is to show that there is
a
connection between the incidence of
thyroid cancer and the glyphosate amount
applied to corn and soy
these correlate
there is no causal link that has been
established
has anybody ever seen this gentleman
this is a british physician called
andrew wakefield
and in 1998 he published a study linking
the mmr vaccine to autism
that study has been thoroughly torn to
shreds
in fact he's been tossed out of the
british medical association he's no
longer allowed to practice medicine
unfortunately
that didn't stop people from thinking
that vaccines cause autism and yada yada
and
let's think of this
what kind of consequences does this
information have
well
the global and the vaccine movement
which is
running rampant especially under covet
conditions but even before kobe when it
comes to the mmr stuff they got a
serious amount of wind in their sales
and we can use that data to push an
agenda and combine probably very
innocent things together
like this
so we can see that the
sales of organic food is going up
we can see that the autism prevalence is
going up
that's all we can see
we don't know why
we don't know why organic food sales is
going up we don't know why
the prevalence for autism is going up
that's it
remember that people see what they want
to see
consider
a family
having a child by being diagnosed with
autism
that is
a terrible experience
and it's not far-fetched to think that
in their grief in their their
fear in their anger they they go to the
internet and they try to figure out why
have their child been struck with this
why has this calamity happen to them
and they find this
they find something to latch onto
we're seeing data
but this is not as much data as it is
the human factor the human condition
everything has consequences
suddenly they have something to latch
onto and something to lash out on
and
we just went from
a fairly innocent visual
to people
in the streets
this is extremely dangerous
what can we learn from this well
just because you can doesn't mean you
should just because you can compare
things and just because you can whip up
funny correlations
doesn't mean you should
everything you do has consequences
and
scale will decide the curve
if i want to i can make just about any
curve intercept another curve as long as
you fiddle with the scales
again don't do that have zero as a
baseline there's a reason for that
and
finally you forget everything from this
session remember this
correlation does not equal causation
just because two things happen at the
same time does not mean that they are
happening because
of each other
it's time to dive into the fifth and
the the final part i should say
we're going to start with the
indian bratia genada party or bjt they
put up um kind of funny thing on on
twitter they they have a pretty clear
agenda right they're political and their
agenda is to make sure that narendra
modi stays the prime minister of india
and like many other political
organizations they kind of play fast and
loose with numbers
i mean apparently the constituents are
roughly as smart as a brick
so they
they put up this on twitter
i'm the first to
to to be very clear i'm terrible at math
but even i figure something is not
entirely correct here
a bit okay so what do we do well let's
defluff it let's take away all the weird
stuff that we're looking at again it's
because of the fluff that we not
immediately see that something is wrong
so let's clear off the bars
there we have numbers
without the bars the mind don't have
anything to latch on to so suddenly we
can see the progression of numbers and
go yeah that's that's reasonable
and we can do it even more than this
what if we were to put back the bars
as it should have looked
huh
that's kind of a different message isn't
it
and this this was obvious
this is what we should have seen
this is a wonderful example of
misleading or just lying to your face
with a visual
they didn't even try to hide it
it's clear for everybody to see
consider how many people actually did
in many ways it doesn't matter if you're
trying if you're convincing everyone
as long as you're convincing someone
well you kind of made your point
oh we're gonna go to the u.s
and this is a bit of a
sensitive issue
i'm not dumb enough to dive into the
latest
election
that's walking on a minefield this is
bad enough so with 2012
there was a the election
that saw the um
barack obama the incumbent uh democratic
president he was challenged by the
republican candidate mitt romney
okay
so this is a map of the
the us the well it's both the
continental u.s and
hawaii
and if we were to color the
states
that voted democrat blue and the states
that voted republican red this is what
we're going to see
there is a lot of republicans here
there's a lot of people voting
republican right
yeah
but it turns out that the states
themselves they're kind of divided into
smaller chunks
i.e counties
and then it looks like this instead
holy cow that is a lot of red
i mean just looking at this map isn't it
obvious
that the republicans should have won it
is isn't it obvious that
mitt romney had
probably won the election
just
look at the number of red stuff
they had their election taken away from
them have you heard that narrative
before
stop this deal
so
okay
this is
the question
should they have won well that was kind
of the narrative that people was trying
to push
i didn't say
they won
i'm saying they should have won
and that's all people need to hear well
obviously they should have won obviously
there is something wrong with the
election pitchforks out and to the
streets we go
and yes there is a lot of things wrong
with the u.s election system but no i'm
not going to touch on that
the thing is
land don't vote
people do
and if you were to look at the number of
voters
per county or actually per state we're
going to see that
there's a heck of a lot of people living
in california
like in california we have millions of
people
and in wyoming we have millions of
cattle
they do a lot of things but they do not
vote
well some of them might do actually but
that's yeah
and and here's the thing
over here we have the people
and if we take that data
and do the math again we're going to
find that ha
the democrats actually did win
because the number of people
voting democrat was much higher than the
number of counties doing so
land don't vote
we have this tendency whenever we see a
map to think that everything is is equal
if we have a map of the us for instance
we tend to assign every area the same
number
so that's why we look at a map to see a
crap ton of red and go huh i think the
republicans won
that is a dangerous thing with maps it's
nothing wrong with the maps it's just
the way we tend to interpret them
meaning that if you were to show a map
you need to consider this
we're going to stay in the u.s we're
going to go to florida
florida is a wonderful state it's warm i
enjoy warm it kind of windy sometimes
that's part of the fun i suppose
they also enacted a law
back in
this so-called stand your ground law
stand your ground is a law that gives
you the right to exercise
deadly force
if
you are being attacked
it gets worse than that
it is completely fine for you to pull a
gun and shoot someone in the head if you
feel threatened
and it's also perfectly fine for you to
shoot the same person in the head again
regardless if you could have
de-escalated by just backing away
so they put up this this is reuters
kind of a big
news outlet they put this up to show
what happened at 2005.
there are a few things kind of sticking
out here when i saw this i literally
poured my
coffee down my windpipe
because
721 is kind of less than 873
how the heck did we manage to do this
visual
well that's why
they turned the damn thing on its head
they turned the visual on its head
this is what it should have looked like
what can we conclude from this well when
they enacted stand your ground the
number of deadly homicides or it's not
technically a homicide it's just
self-defense it skyrocketed who'da
thought that
this is not acceptable
this is an outright lie
by reuters
i
did some research and i found that
somebody had asked the the artist that
did this visual and asked them why
how did you come up with this and the
response was well i wanted to show how
the blood flows down
i'm gonna call on that one
speaking of let's go to the uk
again
the uk
um from the start of the pandemic
they've been
putting out the weekly kobe 19 report
it's been identical
since the start of the pandemic in 2019
and this is what
uk has looked like so we have a map we
have colored areas showing the um
the prevalence of of kovid all right so
this was the case up until week 40 of
2020.
from week 40 and onwards they slightly
tweaked it to call it the
weekly kobit 19 and seasonal flu report
because they're adding the seasonal flu
as well and as we can see back in week
40 the uk finally managed to break the
covid infection
everything was fine in the uk
in the week 40.
or was it
there is
no difference between the report of week
39 and week 40 apart from this
look at the scales
they changed the scales
and thus they changed the coloring
there is
no information about this
nothing
how do people
look at this data well they're probably
going to look at it and go
yeah
everything is much better i'm gonna go
buy stuff
or i'm gonna go without a mask god knows
what
you don't do this
people see what they want to see we want
this pandemic to be over trust me i do
and when i see something like this well
apparently it's kind of normal
so um
where do we go from here well
people have limited attention span
people are not stupid no
god no that is not what i'm saying but
people have a limited attention span and
just like i can choose who i ask and
what i ask
i can pretty much guarantee
that you're going to draw a specific set
of
conclusions that makes me with data
infinitely more dangerous than someone
just screaming
and
always
be careful with maps
because as i said we have a tendency to
ascribe a map a specific number all the
the different areas of the map has the
same value if you will that is something
that is intrinsic to our minds that's
how we've learned to look at maps i.e be
very very careful when you're dealing
with colored maps so called choropleth
maps
visuals are powerful
most of us are predominantly visual
meaning that we
assign
more
impact to visuals
and again how many people actually look
at the data we look at the visual we
correlate with what we want to see
there we go
my goal was to show you how easy it is
to trick people with visuals
and when i started building this session
out i i had it in my head for a long
time and i started building it out
roughly two years ago
and i wasn't expecting to find
just as much shenanigans as i did
i mean it's rampant the stuff people do
and even established news outlets
occasionally make mistakes and if you're
tired of the mistakes just go to look at
fox that's not a mistake that's
intentional
and this was hilarious
for a bit
because i realized
how much crap is out there
and if these fairly basic
things
managed to fool so many people
what is it out there
that i didn't even see
i am in no way immune from this
information and crappy visuals
i like to think that it is harder to
fool me than most people who do not
spend their entire day working with data
but i'm sure that i will be
easy to fall as well
so the question is
are we doomed
well
no
i don't think so
i don't think so unless we choose to be
everybody has a choice we always have a
choice to be better
i can always be better tomorrow than i
was today or yesterday that is a choice
that's how i go through life i want to
change i want to learn
i think it is still possible to make
people
well basically help them think help them
realize that things might not be as easy
or simple as they seem
we crave simplicity we
sadly we can't have it
and
i think that solution is just as
obvious as it is rare
the solution is called data literacy
training
we know automatically to
well how to interpret red lights right
we know not to buy things from strange
men in alleys
we know not to eat yellow snow these
things are obvious it's they're they're
called common sense
and they're common sense because we've
been told this over and over and over
again
what if we were able to make
charts and reading charts and reading
data equally common sense
what if we were able to teach this and
and this kind of of them
critical thinking in school
what if we were able to give our kids
the basic insights
like this
in school
how difficult do you think it would be
to fool them
there are many many ways of doing this i
highly recommend any of these books
anything by by um
alberto cair is fantastic uh we have a
personal favorite of mine hans rusling
uh he was taken from us way too early
he had this fantastic way of
making data approachable making data
easy to relate to and no
he never
made anything too too difficult
it's both interesting and exciting
though so don't play me
if you start to read this and kind of
fall into the
the very very deep hole that data
visualization is it's a fantastic field
so many many
impressive people writing stuff
so much interesting information
so much insight into the human condition
and psychology that you might not expect
when you went in there
we've seen examples of everything from
fairly innocent mistakes to outright
lies so what can we conclude from this
hour well we can for starters with great
power the sorry i had to again i do
power bi comes great responsibility it
is up on you
that does the visual to think about how
can this be interpreted
i'm not going to give anyone who just
whipped up a visual and well it's up to
you to figure out what you're looking at
no it's the person that crafts the
visual that has the responsibility to
make sure that it is as clear as concise
as possible
and
we see what we want to see
every
day
it's the same mechanism
underneath racism
for instance we see what we want to see
as soon as something happens that fits a
narrative that we know
well we're just
going with that's the fact it supports
my facts something else comes along that
does not conform to what i know
what do i do
i discard it
it's apparently something strange
so that's how the mind works
and i still think that
increasing
data literacy is key
we can sort this
it's not going to be easy
but it can be done and it must be done
it must must must be done
i want you
well let me rephrase that i challenge
you
to go out and help others become more
data literate you might not think it but
this hour has given you more points in
the daily literacy column
help others
not everyone can go to this or read a
book or see this whenever you hear
something strange related to data
explain things don't just let it
slide we're not doomed yet
not quite yet be observant
be
curious
literate
and you won't get burned
my name is alexander and i thank you so
much for this session
[Applause]